Speaker 1: Kanye West continues his anti-Semitic,
anti-Jewish tirade. He now is making the claim
that a Jewish doctor misdiagnosed him, apparently
on purpose, wanted him to take pills, which could
have then been swapped out, I guess, with poison.
Kania is very much unwell, but I'm going to tell
you why this is so important. And he continues
ranting about Jews controlling entertainment and
media and medicine and on and on drove.
Speaker 2: Me to a point of exhaustion,
which was misdiagnosed by a I'm not going
to say what race, what people are doctor
and what hospital and what media
went to. We know I can't say that
it was a Jewish doctor that diagnosed me of
having a disorder that would have had me on
medication. Right now, at a time like
this, if I was on medication right now,
then one pill could have been swapped out.
Speaker 1: Oh, right. So it's not even that the
real medication that the Jewish doctor wanted him
to take was the problem. It's that if he was on
the medication, the pills could have been swapped.
Speaker 2: It would be Michael Jackson
and Prince all over again. Right.
Speaker 1: But because they might put Propofol.
Speaker 2: In there, I didn't take the
misdiagnosis and I didn't take the medication.
I'm able to speak to you guys, clear a thought and
transparently so. This right here is a chart of
Universal Studios, 20th Century Fox, ABC.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God. Is he pulling up
anti-Semitic memes on his phone?
Speaker 2: CBS, CBS
News. Columbia Pictures. Warner Brothers.
ESPN Sports. Fox News. Washington Post.
Metro-Goldwyn-Mayer. MTV Music Television.
Nickelodeon. USA Today. Wall Street Journal.
The thing is, I skipped over me about five of
them because it was just unclear on this list.
The read are the executives that are Jewish.
Speaker 1: Okay. So listen. There's a lot of
layers to this. It's very clear Kanye should be on
medication, but I don't know what it was that was
being prescribed to him. I can't say this enough.
I know that he said or someone said at one point,
oh, Kanye has been diagnosed as bipolar. Maybe
it's schizoaffective, schizophrenia, whatever.
Lots of those folks refused to take medications.
Okay. Four. So he's having a mental health crisis.
Lots of people who have mental health crises
don't go to blaming the Jews. So we can't just
say he's not really anti-Semitic, he's just
mentally ill. Okay. It can it can be both
things at the same time. He it's really common
that people find reasons not to take their meds.
For him, it's because a Jewish doctor wanted him
to take the meds, which could then be swapped out
with something that could kill him. Carney on his
own, saying this stuff isn't really the issue. The
issue is the alarming and extraordinarily large
number of people that agree with what he's saying.
Look at the comments on YouTube under this video.
And I am sure you will find people agreeing with
what Kanye says. That's the really scary part.
It's an important thing to talk about. He's not
anti-Semitic because he's mentally ill. He
seems mentally ill and he's anti-Semitic.
And the anti-Semitism is coming out because he's
uninhibited. And it's an important distinction to
make. I'm going to be on Dr. Richard Ritchie's
show later today talking about it. See these
clips on our Instagram at David Pakman show
and make sure, folks, if you're watching
this video right now on YouTube and you're not
subscribed, please hit that subscribe button.